listen guys young guys who have
fantasies about MILFs
I want to tell you something right now
you're not ready I used to work at
Dick's Last Resort on the river okay and
um I had a woman come to
wasn't planning on telling the story but
I had a woman come into dicks I was I
was um bartending and she comes in with
her three friends and it was like a
Saturday afternoon
and we were just kind of all flirting a
little bit and then her two friends left
and she stayed she mid 30s probably
and so I'd only talked to like young
women
and so um she's sitting there and I
tried like a I was like oh your friends
uh
your friends left you alone
she goes no I stayed
and I go this was this was right when I
knew I was in trouble
I go you stay by yourself I'm trying to
be you know
Flex guy
angry you stay by yourself I go
aren't you a little scared to be here by
herself and she goes no but you should
be
foreign
and she slid a piece of paper over
nobody ever talked to me like this
before she slid a piece of paper over
and she goes write your address down I'm
picking you up tonight we're going out
and I was like oh God
so I get home to my get home to my
a house and I'm living with two other
dudes who are around 20 21 years old
and um I walk in I'm super happy
and my buddy goes why are you so happy
what are you doing he goes you got plans
tonight I go yeah he goes what are you
gonna do I go I'm gonna a grown-up
you're grown-up I was like she
probably does dishes and goes to the
stores and
oh you bro
and so I will tell you it was the only
time in my life I didn't know what
grown-ups were on dates and my college
wardrobe was pretty Limited
so I just I must have changed clothes
like Deuces is this what a grown-up was
thank you
and so finally she pulls into the
driveway in a minivan
[Applause]
buddy looks out the window and he goes
hey whoa
your mom's here
dude they told me I ran out of the house
like I was going on a play date like
I hop into her van right
and um I'm sitting in the front seat and
I've been practicing like I think like
what grown-ups say to each other you
know
so I just sat there and I put on my
seatbelt
I go so um
do you want to go to dinner tonight
we'll go to dinner
she goes no we're not going to dinner
so then I thought she was like one of
those like cool hit moms I was like oh
so we're going dancing she was like no
we're not going to dance okay what are
you doing she goes we're not leaving the
van
she goes you know where Breckenridge
Park is I go yeah she goes we're gonna
go in the park and I'm like
but I will tell you this where where
dudes like 25 and under anybody in here
25 and under yeah
listen guys young guys who have
fantasies about MILFs
I want to tell you something right now
you're not ready
you're not right you because every guy I
don't think women I don't think you know
a man's ego in bed is so fragile it's so
it's so much more fragile you could you
all don't know the power you have
one that was the worst thing that's ever
happened to me that dude would never
another person in his life
but so you're not ready as a young
person you
confidence you're not ready because a
grown woman knows what she wants
you are not
[Applause]
yeah if there's a dude sitting next to
that girl you're doing something wrong
just so you know
he was like yes thank you
but here's the deal as a young man
because women in their 30s will say this
to you as a young man you're not ready
for someone who you're having sex with
who you think you're doing what you're
you're putting it down
you're not ready for someone to look at
you and go
what the are you doing
I'm doing my this is my move no it isn't
don't do that why are you doing that
that's terrible you're not ready for
that
so I'm in that we're in the park she
pulls in
this actually is so funny we pull into
the parking lot and she looks at me and
we park the car and she looks at me she
goes
help me put the car seats in the back
so we've got out of the car and we
put the car seats in the way
back right here are Cheerios and Yoo-hoo
all over the
so we start to roll around and I'm gonna
tell you I wasn't a really experienced
dude
um even in college I especially that I
still look I'm not gonna lie to you it
took me to around 23 24
to really get used to the fact that the
vagina was so far back
I remember even at like 20 I was
bouncing around here like what why what
is the
like does that do I need a code or
something like is it gonna pop open for
me or
is there a password I need for this area
the dick is here the vagina should be
there nope it's
I wasn't used to how close it was to the
like I was like
so I guess she got tired of me messing
around with the mound area for as long
as I did
and she just slapped my hand
she goes here's what I want you to do
she goes I want you to lay down on the
ground I had Cheerios stuck to
my back and
and she gets on top of me and I go to
grab her hips and she goes and don't
touch me
I said what do you want me to do she
said and don't talk either
she goes all you have to do is not
this up for me
thank you
and then
I felt like a scratching post of some
kind
like
I had I had I had rug burn this is back
when people had rugs you know
but it was like I was like I'm irritated
on the belly area
yo she wrote that it was like uh she did
the full eight seconds dude
gymnast and then but I just if it's the
first time in my life like
so many things happened like
she she laughed she slapped me she cried
like I was like what's happening right
now I had no idea it's the first time I
had ever been you know
dude she hopped off me I was just like
what do I at least get an orange slice
and a Capri Sun
laughs
I like to smoke weed bring it I like to
smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
oh
[Applause]
[Music]